brought to you by msi computers msi  number one in gaming find out more at us  msi com hey guys Jess McDonald here with  only the most exciting news updates  coming out of a three the long-awaited  Final Fantasy 7 remake is happening sony  showed off a gorgeous CG trailer during  their press conference that left the  audience in or Adam Boyes revealed that  Tatsuya Nomura would be directing the  remake with scenario writer has a he  gained negima and producer Yoshinori  catarse also contributing the game will  be titled Final Fantasy 7 remake the CG  trailer showed familiar faces at cloud  and Barris walking through the slums of  midgar the game will potentially land on  other consoles but it will be available  first on ps4 a release date hasn't been  announced as yet but for all the latest  on Final Fantasy goodness and everything  else coming out of e3 and be sure to  stay tuned to games but